Many companies today have made deep
learning a central part of their
machine learning toolkit.
Facebook, Baidu, Microsoft, and Google
are all using deep learning in their
products and
pushing their research forward.
It's easy to understand why.
Deep learning shines wherever
there is lots of data and
complex problems to solve.
And all these companies are facing
lots of complicated problems,
like understanding what's in
an image to help you find it, or
translating a document into another
language that you can speak.
In this class,
we'll explore a continuum of complexity,
from very simple models to very large
ones that you'll still be able to train
in minutes on your personal computer
to do very elaborate tasks.
Like predicting the meaning of words or
classifying images.
One of the nice things about deep
learning is that it's really a family of
techniques that adapts to all sorts
of data and all sorts of problems,
all using a common infrastructure and
a common language to describe things.
When I began working
in machine learning,
I was doing research
on speech recognition.
Whenever I met someone
working on computer vision or
natural language processing, we had
very little in common to talk about.
We used different acronyms,
different techniques, and
collaboration was
pretty much impossible.
Deep learning really changed that.
The basic things that you will learn
in this class are applicable to
almost everything, and will give you
a foundation that you can apply to many,
many different fields.
You'll be part of a fast growing
community of researchers, engineers, and
data scientists who share a common,
very powerful set of tools.